you can be really successful at it i've
met more millionaires who are younger
than me
than i have who are older than me in
like
on crypto twitter
assuming that they're not famous just
people i see in comment sections who are
like 18 or 19 who have like these are
people who have bought it when like it
was super cheap and they just
they've
held on to it ever since specifically
nft twitter yeah or got it from people
become millionaires like the last 10
months with nfts it's crazy yeah okay
i'm not gonna lie i fumbled the bag i
looked at the board apes art was [ __ ]
ugly i was like they are literally so
ugly i don't want them they're dumb and
i was gonna buy 10 of them because
someone had told me to and i was like ah
these things look really gross i still
don't do this i don't buy enough tees
that i don't like the art of
i don't care who they are i don't care
who's doing them if it's not at least
watchable i'm not putting a board ape on
my on my screen or on a chain i'm sorry
i love that cube one that you post on
your twitter the cube the 3d cube with
like the ghouls and goblins inside of it
yeah i just retweeted that actually
they were in my comments no idea what
that project is but they seem cool they
interact with my posts so i showed them
some love there's a lot of underrated
nft artists a guy named sergey out of
miami really fantastic artist
uh i first saw his art in 2018 he does
crypto art and he does this he's a do
what you love kind of thing
going on and so i purchased a bunch of
his nfts no resale value i spent tens of
thousands probably on his nfts
but i bought them because i liked them
and that's what i do with nfts
personally
or they have to have really good utility
so
i buy them to flip them
that's it
yep buy them
yeah one just one
what were those ones the apollon's how
are your pollens doing
this is the problem with the nft space
ninety percent mistake eight thousand
dollars emoji penguins was the best flip
i ever had which was pudgy penguins
pudgy penguins i bought one i bought a
few but i bought one for
six thousand dollars was like two
ethereum at the time
and it i knew it was rare he was he was
looking as like ooh this is a rare one
you should definitely get this i was
like yep all right
fine i had to convince him too he had to
convince me i was like
i'm gonna spend six grand on a [ __ ]
penguin i was like are you kidding me
and
he's like bro do it this is this is
probably a great move
i said all right fine [ __ ] it
and uh yeah it sold
two weeks later for eighty thousand
dollars
wow
that's [ __ ] cool i'm calling him
screaming i'm like i love you so much
i'll invest in anything you ever thought
yeah
are the pudgy penguins still about
valuable yeah funny story with that you
know i'd like to make it known as an
example of what happens in the space the
founders uh which you know we never did
any sponsor to work people always think
that because like we really just love
the penguins we talked about them
they were already blowing up like we we
we got them views yeah but they were
already they were up 10x when i bought
them
they were up you know they were up 2x
when he bought them nice and so
they were still going but the founders
basically
i don't want to say rugged but they
basically did another mint of miniature
penguins took the ethereum and basically
said all right guys see you later thanks
for the bag
calculator yeah i sold mine way below
floor for half an eighth you know this
was my nft profile picture on twitter
and i've always rocked with the penguins
community's great founders left them
dead and hanging that's the problem like
there's no where's the accountability
for these web three projects for these
nft projects specific and that's like
you know if and if crypto is in the
early adoption phase right where the you
know the early adopters or the early
majority is getting in
nfts are the the before the early
adopter phase i mean
if you look at who who owns an nft right
you can see the accounts on openc i
think it's three million and a lot of
those are probably people selling to
themselves i'ma keep it real with you uh
but we will see nfts integrated in a
major way just like we saw crypto kind
of blow up in 2021 it's sort of like
2017 for nfts right now
so i'm probably gonna buy more
probably as much nfts as i do crypto
during the bear market right yeah
absolutely
anyone who doesn't is a fool in my
opinion no financial advice
and some ifts aren't just art some nfts
are like would people understand like
nfts are like passes for things yeah
like like the yacht club the apr club
like you're you're a member of a club
and you can get the discord you go to
the parties
but even even more so they can they can
make you more money past that so like um
we just uh well so me and my friend
joshua jake who's a business partner of
ours as well uh we just joined as
advisors to this nft project called the
blockchain miners club
and you know they minted these nfts
right they're really cool artwork but
they entitle you to a community reward
right and so they basically
took this mint money that they had from
raising from these nfts and they bought
a bunch of bitcoin miners
so they've got all these bitcoin miners
hundreds of them
mining bitcoin and there's some i think
there's some ethereum miners going on
too uh they they've got all this passive
income coming in that they're
reinvesting and and holders of these
nfts are entitled to the community
rewards
it's not a direct investment thing but
you know you get your community rewards
for owning these miners and so things
like that really excite me for nfps this
is what i'm more than anything excited
for is the ability for
people to to actually show the utility
that they have you know and you can
actually burn two of these together to
create an ultra minor which has a token
attached to it which they're trying to
integrate into a couple different
ecosystems but it's really pushing the
boundaries of what is an nft is it just
art well no an nft all an nft really is
is just you know saying that you own a
specific thing and it's like a right so
i have the rights to this nft it's my my
nft
but it can represent anything i mean
this table could be an nft you have a
it's like a deed saying hey this is my
table right it's like a deed it's like a
patent maybe to that to that like ticket
sales are going to be the biggest thing
in nfts i always said i said we weren't
doing this i'd be trying to solve for
ticket sales for sporting events or
concerts or whatever else because as
soon as they square that circle
like
all ticket sales will be nfts it just
makes so much sense it solves scalping
issues it solves royalty issues i mean
we can do that now right you just get to
your little apple wallet and they send
you like the little qr code in your
wallet and it's kind of like kind of
like that so the difference would be is
say you sold like uh you know your jay-z
and you sell you know concert out right
there's gonna be tons of people who like
buy up your tickets especially like we
see all this and then they're going to
try to resell them for
you know 5x the price right before the
show so if you're jay-z you can go in
and if you sell by nfts and each
ticket's an nft
you go in and say well all right that's
fine
but uh every time that ticket's sold
when it gets transferred like 10 20 30
whatever percent of the value is going
to go back to the artist right now poor
people aren't going to be able to go to
jay-z concerts
so you know you can't go to them now
if you're poor
well how much is a jz ticket
a couple hundred bucks probably at least
yeah but if you're doing it with nft and
people are scalping them on the black
market they're gonna end up being
thousands of dollars
nfts don't solve traditional issues they
they oftentimes present new ones right
we see this a lot with projects that get
exploited
and this is actually a really so i don't
know if you've heard this is a great
example uh the blockchain is like
uh you know bringing a bunch of meat in
front of hungry lions and these hungry
lions are are biting at their cage
trying to get in and get the juicy meat
because even though yeah okay it's
immutable great this ethereum is my
ethereum there's no bank
everything else
is still a risk these board apes were
getting sold for you know one point
seven eight point seven eighth recently
just last week because of an api issue
with openc essentially what that what
was happening is that people had them
listed you know six months ago for that
price but they didn't want to pay the
list the listing fee which is ethereum
gas fees are prohibitively expensive so
they would send it to another wallet and
then back again
violating that smart contract but
someone found an exploit where even
though it wasn't publicly available on
the blockchain that smart contract was
still active
so they would immediately buy it uh flip
it for maybe 20 or 30 times what they
bought and make off with you know 100
grand or less than that sometimes 80
grand and so there's a lot of exploits
in the space right now and it's just
like i said part of the emerging
technology that's coming here we're
gonna see these kinks
but still there's more wins than there
are losses i mean
have they fixed that yet
it's open c
i